if I would have testified and something
but I said would have put someone in
prison taking them away from their
family I wouldn't have been able to live
with myself
the shoe at Seattle Federal Detention
Center is an abysmal place it's where
inmates go when they are sent to
solitary confinement where they are
locked up for 22 to 24 hours a day with
extremely limited access to human
contact and other prison amenities being
in solitary is really hard
you only get one phone call a month
which is really difficult but you have
to be strong that's what I teach is you
like the only thing we do all day is
just
not break I was in my cell 24 hours a
day I was allowed one one hour out but I
never went to recreation because it was
just being put in a slightly larger cell
that didn't have a toilet mat Duran and
kto were sent to the Shu for a crime
that they weren't even suspects in they
weren't charged with anything and they
weren't serving out a prison sentence
they were held in contempt of court for
refusing to testify in front of a grand
jury because of their political ideals
and they were imprisoned as an attempt
to coerce them to cooperate I don't
believe in putting people in prisons and
now that I've been to prison I feel
that's so much stronger from the get-go
I never had any intention of wanting to
be used as an instrument by the federal
government in light of the fact that
neither of these individuals had charges
pending against them it certainly seems
grossly inappropriate that they were
placed in solitary confinement for the
refusal to testify whatever their
reasons may have been the use of
solitary confinement is extremely
controversial because of its
psychological and physical effects they
can range from sleep deprivation
withdrawal depression anxiety
uncontrolled rage suicidal thoughts the
self-mutilation anyone who's been in
solitary confinement in the United
States has been tortured yeah I would
eminently agree with that the idea of
locking someone in a room for days weeks
months on end and never letting them out
anybody that thinks with know that that
would be a form of torture after kdo and
matt had spent more than two months in
solitary confinement and another three
in the general prison population the
judge couldn't ignore the severity of
his ruling any longer he released them
incited that their physical health had
deteriorated sharply and their mental
health had all
so suffered from the effects of solitary
confinement though even after being
released they were never given a reason
why they were sent to solitary
confinement to begin with they never
received any of the due process that
they're required to provide they were
never given the hearings that they're
entitled to when they're sent to the Shu
what crime could be so egregious that
Matt and Katie 'iz testimony would be
important enough to justify a lack of
due process and use of solitary
confinement in this case it was
vandalism during a 2012 May Day rally in
Seattle it was a largely peaceful
protest but there was a small contingent
who were dressed in black and they were
covering their faces and they caused
damaged to the federal courthouse and
also to some nearby businesses but when
Matt and kbo were subpoenaed to testify
about the May Day activities they knew
it was about more than a few broken
windows Matt and Katie O are self
described anarchists as are the
suspected May Day activists we tend to
live what could be construed as more
normalized I'm a waitress and bartender
Matt works with computers and the
government sees that they might not
necessarily picture an anarchist as in
my pictures someone who is more willing
to talk and give them information but I
think that backfired on them when they
asked me about me and whether I'd not
had been at the May Day protest I
answered truthfully that I had not been
there and they had no knowledge of
events but when they asked me about
other people's political beliefs
friendship associations and living
arrangements I refused to answer those
questions based on people's First
Amendment rights by testifying I
wouldn't ever be able to engage in any
community that organizes radical er or
anything because nobody would trust me
the government knew that neither mad nor
kdo had any evidence of the actual crime
there was nothing that they could
provide the government that would assist
them in prosecuting the individuals who
were responsible for the courthouse
damage a 39 page leaked warrant shows
that the FBI had been tracking the group
of anarchists suspected of the May Day
vandalism Kaplan says that they are on a
witch hunt to find political dissenters
what they were doing was attempting to
propagate fear within the radical
community that if you just happen to
know someone who's suspected of a crime
that you could get a subpoena political
networking where the government is
interrogating people's political beliefs
it's just something I cannot and will
not be a party if I remember being in
fifth grade and first one thing about
McCarthyism even before I really knew
what communism was and thinking to
myself what type of coward does that
what type of coward allows this type of
questioning to go on how could this be
possible with today's oversight over the
court system because Matt and Katie over
some enforce eating instead of a normal
trial there were different rules or lack
thereof at play the veil of the grand
jury absolutely makes the government
less accountable we were locked inside
the courtroom we weren't allowed to
leave at any given point which was a
very intimidating experience we're not
allowed any defense we're not allowed to
know what the grand jury is about
outside of what the prosecution decides
to to let out there is very bad case law
that says that the government doesn't
have to disclose very much to the
witness or their counsel about the
investigation the judge's chambers would
not release any information about this
grand jury because of what they called
the nature of the case the Justice
Department says that this secrecy is
vital to the investigative function of
the grand jury but that also means there
is no transparency if proceedings go
awry if you're not willing to cooperate
with a grand jury's investigation no
matter how illegitimate it seems you can
go to jail for a very long time and not
just go to jail but it seems that the
Bureau of Prisons can put you in
solitary confinement for extended
periods without having to justify its
decision to anyone and this could happen
to any US citizen
Matan kdo aren't completely off the hook
yet they could still be charged with
criminal contempt and they are still
recovering from their time in the Shu
you have moments where you just you
realize you're not okay like spending an
hour and a half at a grocery store to
pick out a yogurt or you know your mom
asking you what you know your plants are
visiting her and just not being able to
think past the next day and
a complete meltdown if I do end up
getting charged with a criminal contempt
of court I don't really have a plan
outside of just slating the next chunk
of life that's mine for prison hoping
for the best
you